un mot encore sur ce qu'on vient de voir
et 68 la tchécoslovaquie est-ce qu'en
voyant kiev vous avez pensé à prague
[Musique]
au mois pour un point le courage
absolument incroyable des gens qui
montent sur les chars pourparlers avec
les gars qui sont dedans
parce que le en tchécoslovaquie aussi
des gens on n'a pas vu sur vos images
mais c'était une image très classique on
voyait des gens montées sur les chars et
souvent c'était des communistes qui
parlait aux gens qu'ils avaient dans le
char leur disant mais qu'est ce que tu
fous là rentre chez toi ta rennes a fait
agir trouver quelque chose
en ukraine de ceux de ce courage
incroyable parce que honnêtement en
monter sur un char faut le faire quoi ce
n'est pas à la portée de tout le monde
et je crois que oui j'ai pensé à ça mais
naturellement je savais que ça n'avait
plus rien à voir
parce que là ya ni socialiste ni
communisme qui soit en cause ni d'un
côté ni de l'autre on parle d'autre
chose c'est le droit des peuples à
disposer d'eux-mêmes et avoir leurs
frontières qui ne soient pas violés
tandis que là les russes ont changé
l'histoire du monde nous savons tous le
l'invasion de l'ukraine est un grand
tournant de l'histoire du monde alors
attendez que la poussière retombe mais
ils ont pris une initiative que personne
ne leur pardonnera jamais c'est d'avoir
violé une frontière en plein europe et
d'avoir bombardé des populations civiles
en pleine europe moi je veux bien qu'on
me dise qu'on en a fait autant en serbie
mais non c'est pas de même nature parce
que la russie est un pays nucléaire et
il a donc faire un chantage là en ce
moment il fait un chantage insupportable
il dit bah allez faites quelque chose
pour voir il ils savent très bien que ne
déclencheront pas une guerre nucléaire
c'est donc la première fois qu'on voit
ça appliquer la stratégie du fou au fort
et nous met au pied du mur d'une action
que personne n'a envie d'avoir à savoir
la guerre nucléaire c'est d'une gravité
qui est pas comparable à celle de 68
c'est beaucoup plus grave 68 bon après
coup sur le moment ça me paraissait
horrible explorer comme une madeleine
mais il y avait si vous voulez l'avenir
un steak ouvert là on a l'impression
qu'ils ont fermé
[Musique]